So I'm going to talk about perturbed combinations in CIL and Richter transformation today.
Here are my disclosures. So here's a summary of the ongoing studies involving perturbed-based
combinations. You can see in the relapsed CIL setting, it's either PV, PVR, PVO, doublet or
triplet. In the frontline setting, you have PO or PV doublet and then PVO triplet. In the setting
of Richter transformation, there are single-agent data and then there are a number of ongoing
studies using different strategies. So in the interest of time and availability of data,
I'm only going to highlight a few studies here.
So first of all, in the relapsed CIL setting, so this is a study within the brewing trial,
a small CIL study. So this is a study within the brewing trial, a small CIL study. So this is a
study within the brewing trial, a small CIL study. So this is a study within the brewing trial,
a small CIL study. So this is a study within the brewing trial,
a small CIL study. So this is a study within the brewing trial, a small cohort of PV or PVR
combinations by my colleague, Dr. Rooker. So this is a fixed-duration therapy, about two years.
Many patients got chemoimmunotherapy and two students got a PTK inhibitor already.
So in the table, you can see the response rate, almost 100% response. In the bottom,
you can see the MRD response kinetics. Despite the response, CRA is not very high,
but you can see with ongoing treatment, you can see deep
deepening MRD responses with both combinations. Now, in terms of progression and overall survival,
here, looking at the data, how to judge that glass half-full or half-empty. If you look at the
Murano trial in the setting of the PTK-naive patients, the two-year PFS and OS is above 90%,
but in PTK-exposed patients, single agent VEN, they only get you two-year PFS probably.
So here are two sets of the patient with PTK-exposed, and you can see the two-year PFS,
with either PV or PVO, in my mind, appears very decent and efficacious.
So based on that data, and there's an ongoing phase three trial comparing VR versus PVR.
So here, because Murano is in the BTK-native setting, so this trial primarily going to
address the question whether Pertor adds anything on top of VR.
So although BTK-inhibitor exposure will be allowed, it would be capped at 20%.
So this trial should be reading out soon.
So we'll see whether PVR is better than VR.
And more importantly, in the BTK-exposed setting, this small cohort, does that inform
us anything there?
Now, moving on to a front-line setting, there are different doublet and triplet ongoing
studies.
So this is a study that we are doing in Mayo, fully accrued hope to present later this year.
It's a MRE-guided Pertor-Venn combination.
You start with Pertor debulking for three months, and then you add Venn.
And everybody continues until 15 cycles.
And then if they are MRE-negative in both peripheral blood and bone marrow, they can
stop.
If either component is positive, you keep going for six cycles more, and then assess
again.
In the end, the maximum treatment duration is 27 cycles.
So again, we'll look forward to see the data.
So this is another ongoing study.
I was thinking, after my PV study, I can do a randomized trial, but Germans did it for
me.
So they're comparing PV versus VO.
With the PV, they have two strategies.
One is a fixed duration, 15 cycles.
The other is more interesting, the MRE-guided.
We're not going to go into the detail how they're deciding the treatment duration, but
this is a very important trial.
A PVO study by MD Anderson showed very high efficacy.
So it's basically on top of a VO backbone.
They add Pertor for one year.
So it's a fixed duration therapy.
But if the patient...
If the patient are MRD-positive by UMRD-5 threshold, they can continue for another year.
So when they presented this data first in the EHA a couple of years ago, the UMRD-4
rate, it was shockingly good.
So this is the update from ASH.
The data remains very robust.
If you look at just UMRD-4 at the end of one year, it's almost 100%, you know, MRD negativity.
If you look at UMRD-6 by Clonal-Seq, still very high, 86 in the blood.
74 in the bone marrow.
I have never seen anything like that.
Additional data who are failing their MRD.
So in patients with high-risk disease, if they have either 17P deletion or T53 mutation,
they actually did very well, or MRD negative.
But the ones who had both 17P and T53 mutation, you have a high proportion of patients who
don't achieve MRD-6 at the end.
Most of the patients were able to stop treatment after one year because they achieved MRD.
11 patients per particle are able to continue to the second year, and most of the patients
are continuing the therapy in the second year now.
Moving on to Richter's, this is the single agent data where the patient received a medium
two prior lines of CIL therapy and two lines of Richter's therapy, yet the response was
50%, very good in a phase two trial.
And then time to progression data here.
If you look at the numbers, it may not seem so impressive, but historically, remember,
after relapse for Richter's disease, the median pre-effects in OS are very dismal.
In fact, with some of the older data, median OS from the very beginning of Richter's is only
one year.
So this data did look very promising at that time.
And they reached out to us to do a synthetic control comparison because that was a single
arm trial.
You know, any kind of comparison has its limitations.
But if you don't do any kind of adjustment, you're comparing apples and oranges, but if you do some
attempt of adjustment, at least maybe you're comparing spaghetti versus ramen.
So here, in terms of PFS to OS, so we matched for age and prior lines of CIL and Richter's
treatment and LDH.
So PFS is slightly better than the usual treatment, which is in our group, about 80% chemo and
immunotherapy in older times and 20% so-called novel HSBTK, you know, PCL2 inhibitors, PD-1
and so on and so forth.
In terms of overall survival, there's a clear difference that Pertol compared.
They're favorable to historical controls.
MDSN also presented a PVO study for Richter's this year, the ASH, very similar treatment strategy.
Here, the only difference is that, you know, because of Richter's, they're going to treat for two
years at least.
And in the end, if patients are still benefiting, they can continue for Pertol for another year.
Now, this is the baseline features.
So colon relationship is usually very difficult to determine here.
There's only three, but all three are related.
So 10 relapsed and five treatment-naive Richters, for the treatment-naive folks, they all had prior CRL treatment.
In terms of response rate, this is a very encouraging, like 80% response rate.
The three patients did not respond and unfortunately died.
Now for the 12 patients who responded, their follow-up data showed us that it seems to be very durable.
Three patients went to allo, two were doing good.
The other unfortunately died from TBHT because that was the second allo for the patient, and no one, that patient got an allo for CRL
before.
For the remaining patients, they are all responding with continued treatment.
So it looks very promising.
Early PFS and OS data looks very good.
And again, remember, you know, for relapsed Richters or even treatment-naive Richters, his CRL data doesn't look so good.
So here, at one year, you're looking at an OS and PFS at 80 to 90%.
Certainly, we're looking forward to see prolonged follow-up and maybe more patients from this cohort.
In the interest of time, I'm not going to read all through, through all these summaries, but portal-based combination seems very efficacious in both frontline and relapsed CRL, and it looks very promising in Richters, especially in combination with different interesting strategies.
All right.
Thank you.